JJ Watt Houston Texans me on the show
how are you JJ how you been man hurts
I'm doing good how are you I apologize
it's excessively noisy it's all good man
it is all good you since you asked me
I'm gonna be very honest with you I'm in
a bad mood JJ I'm not never quiet I'm
late no police has nothing to do with
you Fox just announced that the Emmys
have no host they're gonna go without a
host the Oscars had no host how do I
take this JJ I mean as a host I mean am
I as you know I'm just really big
don't you think you should be offended
personally assaulted don't you I was so
no host work I didn't watch the Oscars
last year how did that big-time movie
stars come on and do something funny and
then and then another movie star would
come on and do something funny but there
was no there was no host and I just you
know this is what I do for a living JJ
and I mean like for instance what if
they said you know we can have 15 guys
rush the passer and and we don't need
one specific major big-time rough pass
rusher how would you feel about that
right well I mean if I was equivalent of
the Rich Eisen a pass rushing what do
you mean by F JJ what do you mean by yes
I mean I mean let's be honest you're
nobody's on the route size and level I
don't have a bug with my face on it you
get you you don't then you might don't
know maybe I do we need a [ __ ]
weirder things but I probably do how you
feeling man how's it going I feel good
it's going well I'm just on a golf cart
here heading back to the locker room at
Lambeau so it's pretty cool
the up here in Green Bay practicing
obviously having grown up watching
crackers as a kid and the history and
the tradition of this place it's pretty
special
no kidding I mean that's pretty cool and
so you're done with the the kiddy bikes
then though you're done with yeah
yeah day one was not very successful
broke a bike pretty sure it was meant
for 35 pounds and under they - I got a
larger bike it worked really well and I
still managed to break the seat at the
very end so I'm all for two on
like I've purchased two bikes now since
being in Green Bay I need to get out of
here before I don't have any money left
in my face so at least your car director
your it's your safe and secure on this
cart right now correct golf cart I don't
think I can afford to buy a new one of
these
I am stimulating the Green Bay bicycle
economy so what is it like to be back in
that state for your brother I mean that
must be pretty cool especially you know
I mean the people the way that they the
reception they had for me yesterday and
day before when we came out to practice
the cheers the sign jerseys I mean it
honestly is there's nothing like it and
and it's just for me to be away for
eight or nine years and then to come
back and have a reception like that and
these people who I know how much they
love the Packers I know how much they
support their team for them to be
willing to support me in addition to
their team is really something special
well I mean you represent the state in
such a great manner and soda now all
your brothers JJ I mean this is it's
it's amazing the watts have taken over
the National Football League you're kind
of that you're kind of the new Manning's
don't you think you're like the
defensive Maddox you know I don't know
about that you know it's really cool to
be able to go back to your phone after
practice and read about how your
brothers faxes went on Twitter or to
have group text messages with each other
and talk about what are your training
camp meals like or what's your guy's
night schedule like what's your dorms
like you know it's right conversations
and not many people in the world ever
get to have with their brothers we're
pretty lucky to have that well it's
difficult to get deep with somebody
while they're driving around on a golf
cart but I'm gonna attempt it anyway I
mean you're 30 years old entering your
ninth season do you think about how much
longer you're gonna do this certainly
with how much you've had to come back
from injury wise last couple years
JJ you know I honestly thought about it
a lot more earlier in my career probably
like three or four years ago and then
obviously with the injuries but I I
haven't thought about it in a while
because I'm I honestly feel really good
I mean I still I'm coming off the
healthy offseason I got to train
properly I got to train the way I wanted
to I'm getting to participate in
training camp fully without know they're
really the restrictions right thing and
I'm feeling good so I really am not
thinking about that and I think part of
that's just as you grow
you know early on I was stubborn I mean
just I knew what got me where I was was
all this crazy hard work and training
and his these workouts but then you have
to learn as you go that you can workout
with the same intensity just a little
bit smarter and a little bit different
exercises and I think it took me a while
to get over my own stubbornness and my
own private fact and once I was able to
do that and learn that I could still put
in the same amount of work just do it a
little smarter I think it's paid off big
time for me so you're not looking over
the steering wheel and thinking okay 33
34 35 that's conversations just not
going on between your temples right now
no it really isn't I'm just I'm so
excited for this season it the guys that
we have in this locker room and to be
able to go out there and play it also it
doesn't know good to look that far ahead
I mean what's what's gonna come of it I
mean it's just like looking behind like
I'm not gonna it does you no good to
look that far back or that far ahead
because it's not going to help you in
any way so I'm just focusing on what I
can do to help us this season right and
and deshaun Watson is a special person
man and he's a special player and I'm
wondering if he looks any different to
you in a year three obviously we all
know what happened in his first year
second year he really got beat up but
you did win a division I'm wondering if
what he looks like in year three for him
JJ yeah you know he continues to get
more and more confident I think the
especially at the quarterback position
in this league there's so much going on
and so many things you have to manage I
think the further into his career he
gets the more more comfortable he is and
he is he's a special player he's a
special guy and I think he's really got
a good command over what they're trying
to do over there and he he takes command
of that huddle and he he's a leader he's
a good leader and he shows those guys
what they need to do and the work ethic
they need to have it's good it's good to
have a QB one over there and to know who
he is and I know he's the guy in a few
minutes I have left with you here and
left in my program actually are you
gonna play tomorrow night are you gonna
sit this one out do you think no no I
don't really plan a whole lot of the
first preseason games and I don't think
this will be any different you know
obviously it being Lambeau I'm excited
just to get out there and warm up I'm
excited to play catch with the fans and
just to take it all in experience this
year because I haven't had a chance to
do it before so it's going to be it's
going to be pretty special even though I
won't get
therefore any game reps but it's uh it's
an unbelievable place with so much
history and in terms of special I mean
tell me about that family you had at
camp yesterday JJ tell me about yeah you
know they were three little kids and the
mom unfortunately they lost their father
recently he was a firefighter and my dad
was a firefighter my uncle was the
firefighter so firefighters first
responders of all kinds are obviously
extremely close to my heart so we had
him out here practice which was
specially got to play catch with him got
the mess around and they reminded me of
my brothers and myself when we were
young I mean there were three little
kids I'm all about the same age as my
brothers and I had and you could tell
they wrestle they fight they get under
each other's skin but at the end of the
day you can see the love and you can see
how much they care for each other and so
for us to be able to have them out of
practice and help take their mind off of
obviously two extremely difficult
situation was pretty nice and it was it
was a really cool moment well JJ
Congrats on getting engaged man I'm just
glad that I'm glad that I got engaged
and married before you did it because
you showed us all up
brother with all those photographs you
really do thank you I appreciate I had
to do something special you know she's a
very special girl and I'm very very
lucky to have her see she's one of the
main reasons I got through those tough
years I had with the injuries and
everything so I'm very thankful I'm
grateful to have such a special woman
okay and before I let you go here are we
gonna put something on the line for the
third game of the regular season in the
college football campaign JJ were you
and I gonna do some third game I haven't
even looked at the where is it come on
you don't know you really don't know I
know your training camp here okay break
okay man
it's Michigan at Wisconsin your house
you're alright are you going no I got to
work just like you I do not sir
I do not I have mom but I have no
helicopters I'm helicopter mom yeah you
let me know what it is I mean oh okay
here yeah yes if we win you send me our
I send you a marker with my face on it
you gotta check out of it for a whole
show okay if wishing and all and I do
win I'll take I'll drink out of the Rich
Eisen bargain send your photograph move
a ass JJ Watt
and put it on all of your Instagram and
Twitter feeds with a billion people yes
yet that's there you go in in okay all
right I like it thanks to the call Brian
I'll call coach Chris now you give it a
good place you take care of yourself JJ
hey you got a brother that's JJ want
Texas defense event for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app